I'm thinking we're back with broadcast
oh sorry
welcome back to ginger and I thought I
heard hi 550 another that Matt deliver
hang another week with gifts so that's
the first guest that's ever intercepted
our hive yeah we normally try to
high-five like in front of them that's a
really weird Oh see that's a lemon what
out really nice that Delphi this week we
have Keaton and Matt from techsmartt oh
thank you guys for joining us bad yes
we're excited to have both of you thank
you for your fresh off a plane
you just got fresh I dropped out
seriously fresh off the boat and you
know what I bet you were probably doing
in this guy I mean I won't
I won't I'm almost positive you were on
headspace because you were probably
training your mind for a healthier less
stressed life through the headspace app
what you guys can do today right now you
can do the take 10 challenge which is 10
days of free guided meditation go to
headspace calm /gen Julian to get
started thanks for that I'm gonna try
that
I appreciate using an app that's really
cool I know it was great yeah oh yeah I
need your headphones here your phone
you're good yeah so okay so I feel like
it's been a little long time coming to
have Keaton on the podcast yeah he's way
up north
he's what do you call it if we're not
gonna say there's a name for we can't
say on the podcast abaqus I probably for
the best
yes so you want to move a little closer
we can hear you just yeah go like this
are good I'm just relaxing I want to
talk about the fact that Matt just flew
in from Rochester just for this he's
leaving the night just for this no just
for this dinner sure just the boy I am
like I would I believe anything
especially with candy thanks pretty
commit to it as that oh yeah she knows
that though keep staying at the house
for a weekend teens freedo never again I
just yeah Rochester we're from a town
over from each other our towns our
rivals your mom's know each other yeah
yeah this is crazy small world
what's it if you're both moms live in
Rochester it's not that crazy that they
know each other but it is that crazy
that they live in Rochester and in
Rochester so do you so live like you
live there yeah like I was in Pittsburgh
like the house I grew up in I'd say your
backboard from here yeah Tex
Rochester how is Rochester great it
actually is really good
I got yeah I was usually go back and
it's like so so with like Whiteman's is
on point
oh yeah that's the grocery store yeah we
were just talking about like like on the
stream someone brought up like mints I
think right yeah
remember cool Enzo's know like she ever
saw it cement or a garbage plate a
garbage plate he's half hours ago do you
like our sweets I love garbage Flo
Shannon is tubing max I'm max gallons
max out scares me yeah no no wait scared
what do you have it scares you it's
pasta in salad or pasta sauce right yeah
when people can't have a guard I can't
eat it you can eat a vegan we should
make a vegan garbage my friends another
JJ's kitchen right there that's true we
should do that and what about brown
beans can you do baked beans
no but there's they have like meat
substitute right you can use and then
all you need is just the vegan mac
affray what else comes on a garbage
plate you can pick yeah you can do you
could do like a Turk like a veggie
burger on the top and sounds like a
cheeseburger Oh got it
what did you since when is that a choice
since you probably crazy you put like
geographers impressive you ever been
there yeah no I mean like a long time
ago and it was just like you can get two
cheeseburgers two hotdogs or like a
godfather which is like everything okay
some chairs that I can baby get that oh
really good child you get the clothes in
all really good childhood yeah it sounds
amazing
remember this little towards their
Rochester is nice there yet it still
still sucks it got warm yesterday but
it's been like 50 degrees so oh yeah
it's in a bad spring bad spring combines
better than Pittsburgh that isn't
concerned awesome all right Keaton Oh
golly it's for brains better than
Pittsburgh a brain is better than
Pittsburgh why don't we revisit this
argument a little bit come back to this
little time death next week let's go
the Chairman a social experiment hell
that's true that's true I think the
problem is that there is no answer to
that Brighton and Pitt's ready both
equal good well they're both in
Rochester so how good can they be yeah
Ryan is a better softball team in
Pittsburgh okay I don't think he's
arguing I'm yeah okay
you run that that's what's I what is
your a softball yeah I played college
soccer all the way through college
she was the UH captain in sophomore year
at college junior junior actually I
don't remember Wow guys some captain a
little background I tagged smart for
those who don't know right now
Keenan and I run a channel called tech
smarts youtube.com slash tech and they
make really interesting cool tech videos
and they have for quite a while you used
to live in Jersey Chicago Chicago huh it
was your buddy who lived yeah Phil
Phil's always just watching videos
yesterday I guys back into history he's
live in Chicago you moved out here and
you're continuing videos uh for anyone
who's seen your videos knows that
they're not I like to call them not run
in the mill tech videos yeah not that
you know like there's also many tech
videos and tech channels out there and
yours just doesn't blend in with them
yeah I don't know you're just kind of
like I saw I used to try to be someone I
wasn't and just try to do the cookie
cutter the cookie cutter kind of like
let's make a voiceover let's see these
shots and like honestly that doesn't
matter if you have personality if you're
passionate I make videos I wanna make
them send me with Matt and I that's just
what works really well for us
you know yeah I honestly think like I've
been watching you for a while now and
I've seen you kind of come into your own
yeah we were friends for a while you saw
I see the progression yeah absolutely
well because there's been a lot of it oh
yeah I mean I used to just sit on my
couch not give a [ __ ] is just me on
jamás even before that I watch them all
the old Keane videos and my favorite
thing in the world is a solid I think
you're like twelve or so yes we ate fire
you do that can you discuss right now
how old Keaton is chasing teen is 18
days 18 years old to give you some
colleges on 19 19 18 and 19 so they're
kids
yeah what is Julianne your kid - I'm 22
man I'm 40 uh you guys are on a platform
doing your own thing like and you have
been for a long time and as of now how
long have you been doing videos it'll be
six years in December I was 18
just to give you some yes oh so you go
you were whined all the way back to the
beginning and you see a little tiny
Keane with braces and a lot Mike
yeah well bike any uh you need some work
any other the whole time we've been yeah
how have you had more news for yeah good
five years yeah like yeah mad at YouTube
channel that's all like found found of a
man we just like started talking and
then and you were in Chicago you were in
pen yeah it was just like what does like
meet people through the internet kind of
thing and like we farmers all me calm
yeah free singles doctor would be free
that's a [ __ ] thing right but is it
really it is free stuff but yeah that's
like how I made friends and averages
there are kind of relationships just
like builds and we've done like we went
to Australia together in the fall
phenomenal so you guys do all sorts of
crazy trips like that where you're
getting places for specific videos that
like they're not guaranteed you gonna
have to pull them off once you're there
exactly we sent some trips were like it
doesn't go done this success yeah you
were in Australia for that so okay what
was that why cuz I I follow along that
it looked pretty yes you saw the outside
perspective like I just smiled out yeah
that was like a blur for you I feel that
was our fret our other friend who was
there as well go oh yes go ahead
okay so we went to Australia to do the
success like to drop like first right
because Australia first time zone in the
world that get early I know is insane
yeah that's so you guys went to
Australia to get the phone before
Americans or anybody else because the
time zone oh yeah time zone and like
sounds crazy but like that's the
difference between like getting the big
video or not getting the big band so
we're in Sydney and we camped out for
six days yes I didn't need his camp I
did have over six days we found out that
you have just pre-ordered an in-store
pickup and showed up at 4 a.m. that
morning but you guys were there for six
days experience it was Defence Academy
for good prostitutes came up to Matt try
to solicit him for services and vice
versa
thank God for snapchat yes that's true
we made an entire video on it my waited
weekly iPhone success so how did that
video do it's a pretty well got like
tutor K and but back then dropped us all
the drives it drives a contest on polio
in and one point yellow yeah she dropped
a CD review though oh we did it
you oh is that what that was remarried
in oh that's right I was unclosed above
the phone early alright sorry about that
guys we uh we had a technical difficulty
but we are back now uh anyway where were
we so alright so hi mr. Australia well I
wanted to talk about you guys have been
doing like I feel like your videos have
been more and more Keaton based they're
less what's in my hand and more like
what's in my hand and also who I am and
I feel like that's cool because your
channel is growing a lot right now yeah
and there's something to be said about
that because in the tech space there
really aren't too many personalities
that's true I mean as a consumer I don't
really off the top my head I can't be
like oh I like this guy's personally
when you reviews tech I just like I like
its videos its quality videos but maybe
it's not like I don't want to go there
relate to him and I feel like you're
kind of bridging that gap which is kind
of cool I mean that's obviously like it
it's something you're working on and
trying to do right yeah I think I think
I want to hear Matt's opinion on this
but like when we started in January when
that first came out here to like live in
California just like with the channel um
it was more we were trying to find our
style because like in the fall I added
just I don't give a [ __ ] attitude like I
wore pajamas in 95% of the videos I
remember beautiful like if I can go back
that time yellow backpack era yes
Oh still yo so DMX is not in every
frickin shot now do you wanted to be
Julianne no I don't I'm really good
riddens canary yellow backpack so well
he was just kind of like that and that's
kind of what helped develop the
personality because I kind of just felt
lost prior and then when that came out
here I really my big focus was quality
and just kind of making the channel just
enjoyable everybody you watch the big
thing with like what we do which i think
really sets it apart is every video we
make we want you to have a good time if
you don't care about tech perfect I
don't care but I want you to be able to
enjoy yourself I want you to learn
something new check out something you
wouldn't see on any other channel and
that's what we try to embody in each and
every video I think we do that 100% to
the best of our abilities anything Matt
is like a producer of all the videos
she's been able to amp up the quality
cut the [ __ ] cuz I like to ramble
and just kind of make them good and
enjoyable I don't know what do you know
that's yes pretty much guys you guys
work
all together fe yeah you give each other
in fact pretty well yeah it's a nice
checks and balances going on
okay so right now it's May
yeah what is the next huge thing that's
going to happen for you guys in the tech
world like is there a release is there
something about WDC which stands for
like the Worldwide Developer Conference
so every year that have cropped up yeah
mmm our good friend Will Smith Will
Smith lien um patented the word dubbed
apart started saying in our friend group
and I never sometime it has stuck okay
but it's like when they papal yeah it's
when they show off the new software you
like your iPhone and I know you've been
reluctant to upgrade to software Jenna
just bang right now she was on I was a
for like really sure what the Mac
outlook that's imagine so we'll see I
was trying it I wasn't convinced I wanna
drop David iOS and sold me I wish people
okay she sometimes our audience we all
like Apple stuff like service fan but
hasn't sold you but every time I show
you a feature you're like oh how do I do
that will you update general it's not an
ambulance the action song oh my god okay
um I was said yeah
what are your I mean can you talk about
what you think's gonna happen like do
you think is gonna be anything kind of
mind-blowing merchants one of my friends
sunny dick said he's like really big in
the Apple world yeah he um he says the
lockscreen is really cool that's all the
that's all the log screen is a lock
screen is gonna be dope okay take it
with a grain of salt
cuz like I haven't seen it there's been
nothing else about it but like these are
got a pretty good track record and
that'd be really dope to see a cool
lockscreen like that's something that
stayed pretty much the same for require
that just like I feel like I was still
mad all you've ever this is like I'm
gonna win there's a lot about their info
Julian either it's gonna be okay
remember iOS 7 is different like yeah
member iOS 7 though like a big change
yeah if we don't see that again like
it's over time to revamp the remember
like the flat ion different message like
everybody control sunny this way yeah
everything got changed like Iowa State
was the repeat iOS 9 was repeat like for
the most part yeah change
the same style that they created I was
seven like you could look at I was seven
and just you quickly showed something
they wouldn't know if that was Iowa
seven eight or nine
so the change between six and seven
needs to happen again from that's what
we need from nine to ten interesting
very simply said and if that doesn't
happen there's gonna be a lot of upset
people if you like apples kind of
pissing people off all right
so they didn't have record quarter
didn't have record earnings yeah I mean
what do you think of the five the five
see right son - Anson SE se SE se um we
own one ah it's a good phone for people
who like small hands I still feel like
people are getting screwed for five
hundred dollars and I don't feel like
that's what a lot of it's worthy I think
maybe the second gen would be great but
like hi it's 2016 don't sell me
something for $500 that doesn't have
same the same specs is like a success
you know yeah I'm not just like I'm pink
MacBook Pro WC paying back booking for
pro yes fire that if that fired I've got
a match a pink phone in our big shirt
yeah yeah pair you look pro what cuz the
rose gold I mean they don't yeah Rose no
janus janus completely lost no I just
[ __ ] nail you don't knife on his John
what have you had it with what have you
had with I just I don't want a pink
MacBook I want it to be better than the
one that I currently own that's it
period
what are you cargo which I don't even
know then that back or the it's it's at
it's not the 23 it's like 2010 or 2011
so it's like it's a metalic Pro but not
retina it's just after like iBook g4 oh
that's like the first MacBook oh my god
it was not good that's all so just the
original MacBook Pro I think yeah okay
anything is better than even my yeah but
even my 2013 retina right now is Sloan
yeah yeah the more you shoot in 4k no
not much
okay times but not much okay but yeah we
should die hoping WD sees great now we
used to in the past and this is a good
so where is it it takes place in San
Francisco just get our every year at
services good yeah just different done
Apple watch too but I hate that blush so
I'm more saying that the reason for et
x1 right on the Apple watch - yeah so
whatever the next iteration will be
talked about all interested there I was
like can you let it out
second why do you hate the Apple watch
cuz I actually smart wat when if you
preach pebble so I will kill here
relationship with time a Russian house
oh yeah I guess I can't give it unbiased
opinion but the reason I hate the devil
is it does it they connected my phone
but you're the old versions every
thought no it's not my phone it's not I
got Bobby from my great phones once a
month okay well once a month I get any
probably more often than they're so true
yeah so I took a picture the Bluetooth
says disconnected but yet it's still
connected like like hi like get it get
together like I bought three watches
from Kickstarter because that's the
business model get it together
come on and get it together so now let's
let Matt talk about pebble the company
that he's relationship Jesus Christ one
that much expensive it's not cheap cost
more than the phone yeah so as much as
the felt with six point three hundred
four hundred dollars for a watch right
yeah that's one two attracts do a lot of
stuff that I don't think we're ready to
do like you don't like do you'd make
phone calls with you haven't have we're
very yeah very rarely this one I'm gonna
trying to be funny right we're trying to
like show off like look with the Apple
watch I think I've done it serious once
when I was like I couldn't find my phone
the delivery guys calling it I was like
[ __ ] alright hello alright but it's like
it's weird yeah it's not it's not
something yeah so I don't think they
should try and put up they should stick
to based on to your wrist just do well
with those things right gives a
notification that a big thing
notifications is cool that's one of the
reasons I use yeah that's the best
feature of SmartWatch is getting
notifications on your wrist yeah hands
are full your phone's in your pocket
someone quickly dings UK I don't care
about that and you go you know what it's
yeah so being able to respond to
messages and that's seen as I'm saying
like that's a lot less important than
knowing that the messages they are
that's the main part I feel like because
of the aisle every time someone says is
the Apple watch worth it and it happens
quite a bit
people are like should I buy I would
always just say the notifications is the
only reason I use it I initially thought
that the fitness part would be why is it
and I don't I know I used it for a while
for that and then I was like uh I mean
sleep tracking school does Apple watch
do that I don't think so because you
have to charge it at night well
is that you you then have to charge it
during the day in order for it to last
while you're sleeping I did it one time
and it was cool but then I was like well
now I can't wear it during the day so
then what the [ __ ] is the point true
that's other thing too I forgot this is
like five days battery so I'm not it's
pebble yeah as a pebble house kind of do
you like it that looks nice
yeah it's like it's cheap it's like 150
bucks I like that that's like that's a
that's a price point that the watch
should be right you know not as
expensive as the Apple watch I have one
I liked it I do like it but it's
frustrating that it cost that much money
right and it's trying to do so much
right and none of which it's really
doing well exactly the one thing I will
say about pebble they have a good
community and like I don't see it with
the Apple watch like the apps on there
are good the watch faces are great I
like that just connectivity to my phone
like if you want to send me a phone
pebble like just cook about that but I
think because watch I think with the
next couple um I'm really excited to see
like where it goes and just like what
that means for smartwatches cuz like
being in this industry like wearables
wearables where we see these trends kind
of like on YouTube you see like pranks
tears rant channels all that stuff we
see it with like wearables rod phones VR
360 videos like god that was a big deal
this is kind of the last year for it and
if it doesn't work what's wearables are
gonna be if I know there's a reason you
don't see everyone and their mom wearing
an Apple watch or you up you don't
saying everyone has not felt like
everybody has an idea not everybody has
an Apple stretch because it hasn't
reached that point of everyone could use
the accessibility part of it like then
will it reach that oh yeah I think
that's a big what if you know yeah but I
guess we'll see like very soon right
yeah I think they have a shot to do it
this year like I hope Apple does it
right am I good if their heads other
asses and like alright we built a watch
and this is what people actually want
yeah so trying to force it what we think
it should be so I don't know well I'm
interested I think I mean it's it's
heavily frustrating cuz you're so
excited for the Apple watch and then it
kind of falls short in some areas and
you're like well now I'm frustrated but
thankfully I know what to do what I'm
frustrated I get on headspace
anytime you feel an emotion everyone
goes through motions every single day
frustration anger stress anxiety they
all start in your head but it doesn't
have to be that way you can get on the
headspace app right now and have guided
meditation what is guided meditation
it's basically you having someone coach
you in relaxing and less stress in your
life through an app on your phone you
get the headspace app and you do guided
meditation it takes ten minutes a day
you do from anywhere as long as you've
your phone your headphones you can be at
work and just head out for 10 minutes
and get some real headspace in guys
meditation in one form or another has
been rooted in thousands of years of
research and and and uh sorry tradition
and research and it's proven it does
stress it does reduce stress in your
life which is huge
wherever you are you can now do ten days
of free guided meditation that's a coach
helping you meditate it's not just
sitting there showing your eyes it's
actually relaxing your mind with
technique which is awesome if you have
not ever tried it it's worth a try go to
headspace comm slash Jenna Julianne it's
very very interesting how it works and
how you realize kind of taking yourself
out of your zone for one quick moment a
day can help you check it out go to head
space.com slash Jenna Julianne and let
us know how you like it
thank you XD oh yes bass you can try out
for frame ten days I want to talk about
something because Keith and I had a
really interesting conversation as
someone like okay I moved question like
please know so we orientated at me
um as someone that's in a different part
of YouTube there's definitely like
different groups you have your tech
community whatever the [ __ ] I do the
beauty guru community but there's a
beauty guru Jenna that's the committee
of [ __ ] yeah I wish um there are
specially different groups and within
those groups it's very competitive
sometimes I know I think that the tech
industry are like on community or I'm
sorry I can't even [ __ ] speak the
tech join Aviv on YouTube
and the beauty guru community are very
similar and that's the fear that's like
[ __ ] what a lot of it but a lot of
what you do is competitive because
you're working with reviews of similar
products and like in the tech community
if you don't get it first because I'm
when we have this conversation a long
time ago you're trying to sway
like with these people that are they
have like it in like they're getting
these products before anyone else so how
are you supposed to be able to [ __ ]
compete with this review and whoever has
at first like you know gets the video
you scream yeah and so how you compete
with that but then I think the beauty
groups may be sort of the same in that
like anyone that has their what was what
is that this is my this is my head no
about how it really makes it my
favorites yeah like the focus its focus
as well sometimes you know I can have it
off to get their hands on a product
first yeah they get like a video for
that because they have the video does
really well but they also get to like it
has to do a technique or like ability
you know they can review old products
and talk about it and all that stuff you
guys don't necessarily sometimes have
the luxury of being able to review old
technology and rave about it you know um
where's the beauty Curie community does
um
what because your your videos are now a
conscious shift into turning them as
more personality driven they're more
Ketan base like I know this was a
conscious choice of yours but like can
you talk about that at all in terms of
like are you happier now like is it less
stressful or more stressful to be
personality based because I know it's
it's yeah yeah um I would say can i oh
yeah I want you to get like the oh yeah
I'm not on me like I'm behind the camera
most of the time if Matt did if Matt
couldn't be known Matt would like that
like Matt doesn't want exist like
massive Instagram I have a snapchat in a
visco campus doesn't earn a nabisco I
like toast pages on this go but actually
an actual place where you can post place
with beautiful be that's exactly that's
exactly what I wonder if that was just a
filter a perfect the right ready so what
do you thoughts having looking in from
outside and like rarely being on camera
because you do appear sometimes I do
fear sometimes I've done I've done my
fair share virals don't
yeah five million view videos yeah I'm
not mad does it's a million or more yes
if I should you know true a good one
that I would say is okay here's a good
happens used to Rihanna headphones yes I
did
that's close good like that's a beauty
crying laughing you like that one right
I like that that was a perfect example
like we got that first if we had not
whoever got that first had that video
right I could give some context these
are $9,000 headphones that Rihanna took
an Instagram picture that looked like
that tiara and then teen got ahold of
them to hook them on his head and looks
like yeah they sound mediocre I think
what you like sort of treated it like a
serious dope essence they were so I'm
watching your [ __ ] video it's gonna
be like well I just took questions like
music supposed to sound like I had to
take a pause like I was just like my
missing so funny year creating so that's
a perfect example like any anyone in the
tech space could have gotten there I
mean me nine thousand dollars to bring
me up for the headphones but like anyone
who got that first had the video and
like there was not going to be a double
video for that but you know if someone
had posted that and we got B to it we
probably want to very probably I mean if
I risk 9 K I'm gonna make him you know
exactly like tribute I've had to do a
different tip we would have always
having to do that but not the Mishnah
you get to that so like that was a good
example of like we got that first and
the same thing again we just did the 3d
printed shoes we got our hands on that
like again we're the only like no one
else for wanna 44
yeah 144 for starters cool yeah of the
shitty shoes so it's already gonna be
hard enough people to get them but like
we got those first so we did the videos
like we beat that there but there's
definitely been times like where we've
gotten beat and we've had to scrap stuff
for sure yeah and I wish it wasn't that
way and I but but by driving the
personality you can kind of then you
don't have to worry about you have to
rely on and after a while I think we're
like are with our relationship like you
and I both know like if we weren't first
with the iPhone we were just like ah
well that's been a great year same thing
with like the drops like I used to get
really big anxiety over this and like I
freaked Matt out because I guess I'm
stressed math get stressed
I know that's like secondhand stress
from Keaton EPS yeah that's true yeah um
but I don't know I think most recently
started to happen like where we've been
beat on products that um you know I
might have made a video on a month
earlier not gonna say who but um uh it
just kind of comes down to personality
and like why you want to go I mean I
hope at the end of the day that you're
interested in the product and me and if
that's both and it's win-win if you're
only interested in one of the other
that's okay but um well I love the
balance that you have yeah you do you do
kind of you know dabble in both arenas
which is huge for the channel that you
guys have it's like we don't really have
one thing we kind of have a couple of
different avenues that we can strengthen
our channel with and it's it's obviously
nice seeing a channel you know with
great audio great lighting and
technically great but also like you have
really maybe not you know everyday items
that you're reviewing you're reviewing
your selfie spoons yourself you [ __ ]
like things like that yourself again
it's been washed times and again it's in
in the boxwood
rental next time that's what I did
specifically more we've really like
really reached out so like we're not
doing iPhone cases or like traditional
yeah we really read I yeah years like
nothing is a texted no and absolutely I
think anyone who does watch your channel
can attest that like if you're to ask
them like you know where where would you
find items being reviewed that you would
not find anywhere else and that's that's
your channel you know which is really
cool um that I mean that's just thinking
about getting these products and
sometimes getting them first that
stresses me out oh it's it's very
stressful and my cell mad about it every
time like I come up with like an idea
and it's sometimes it's it dives good
hell them back to get them D out like
I'm a very determined individual and
like I do do want my any criminals
robbed miking himself is a determined
individual thanks Dylan I appreciate
your getting squeaking around the
internet alright guys if you are to go
to techsmartt go you to drag on slash
tag go to the older videos
so amazing it's all there's no it's
hilarious either by the bathroom they're
great the bad back huh
I'll show Jenna the picture yeah well I
mean what you've done for yourselves
though that you had to happen you've
created a longer-term business plan than
just our ability to get our hands on
technology first Julian picture of him
as a man do that hair yeah would you
decided though that you're worth
investing more into than anything else
within your business yes which I think
takes a lot of courage to do being like
you know for the time being maybe I'm
not going to get these videos that are
getting all these use because I'm not
getting my hands on this technology it
might take a little while to grow this
channel but then people are invested in
you personal challenge evety do that
yeah that's in my opinion it's a smarter
way to create things is when people are
coming to see you personally along with
some things that you guys enjoy and I
think with my audience being so young I
mean the patient's young yeah 13:18
mostly oh demo so um but it's also like
everyone's demo is mostly that yeah you
know whatever yeah because that's the
majority people consuming on like the
tips but with the tight channels it's
different really did I meet her I mean I
think we're probably when the other yeah
we're probably on the lower end of like
ages yeah for sure well you're also on
the lower end of ages yeah that's what
Appeals know totally like thirteen year
old can relate to me versus afraid yeah
honey percent Yeah right if you're
watching some guy who has a kid and like
is it bad and you're 13 years old that's
not as later was like key yeah I'd be
like if I want to see my dad review tech
I'll walk to the kitchen that's good um
but yeah I think I think the best part
about having a young audience is I'm a
very pop culture person and I make a lot
of pop-culture references and if you
look at the comments go on any video
you'll just have a great day to get some
popcorn I just read the comments they in
the cons
they are nasty they have some fun with
you Oh exactly then I could care less
but it's nice having a young wannabe
it's a given but you learn in the grow
it is tough love like they are back the
next video that's like exactly for
watching our video
you like to show this guy Keaton is is
this is that but then they're there the
next artifacts exactly the same thing so
obviously there's high specs we use yeah
like why do you keep going back if you
leave all this crappy comments like
you're right there on the next video
obviously you're interested in obviously
you know you know yeah so you guys have
a schedule right now it's every Sunday
and what was your auditioning you
mentioned this yes what up that Tuesday
Friday Sunday and we're about to do men
are talking but front of me on Monday
Tuesday through Friday Sunday which one
did you say Friday or traditional Monday
in there and that's like a heavy she
said it's a bit like you had other
different day a different thing or yeah
it's gonna be huge it's a different
video I want to start rolling out some
more series that a lot of my audience is
like requested but I don't know I feel
like I'm not doing enough but then I
also like feel like I'm overwhelmed
cuz yeah I have to find I'm trying to
pursue and we've had this conversation
yeah um I'm trying to show the platforms
like I'm really trying to get into
acting and skits and that's what I've
been doing with like a lot of my other
friends on like my Facebook page your
new are musically I've heard right yeah
I mean when my twitch that's actually
making noise that's a great part of a
music you don't think in saying oh yeah
big I'm gonna link your channel I'm not
gonna like your music guys I don't leave
your time 130 followers on the Haggadah
oh my god um well yeah no that's I'm
honestly excited to see like worried
because with the change in the last year
I'm really excited to see what you guys
yeah it's all gonna be techy as you new
for tech videos we do well I don't
really consider them all bein a 3d
printed shoes like they're just like
digit happen to be made with tech right
Rhianna headphones they just happen to
be pair headphones like fun do you
probably come to the chin yeah their
products are not like but it's not let's
review a graphics card like that works
for you and your audience greatness I
don't care about yeah that's like tech
tech and like I think with each video
that meant I pick out to do they relate
to people or with awe like in any age
any demographic and like they're all
very interesting no matter if you care
about tech or not yeah that's the
hardest part is getting the products
natural yeah
oh yeah oh yeah are not hardest part is
I like we use
right there you're you're getting people
interested in tech who normally wouldn't
be interested in Jack it's it's kind of
like that channel frog leap Studios he
does metal covers of pop pop songs yeah
oh yes it bridges the gap for you it's
like it makes an average person
understand why someone like metal you
know what I mean
which is kind of similar what you're
doing for tech which I think it's cool I
want to know what you guys think about
unboxing videos okay uh just this 2012
again you go there you there you know
the channel unbox therapy yeah he's like
he's crushing it yeah he does a great
job at what he does um how do you think
about unboxing videos because that is a
box of ten boxes no no yeah he used to
do just unboxing I definitely focus on
like here's what it looks like your
sales package and now it's more like
review II but I'd say like unboxing was
like big I've ever won a box it was huge
and like you wanted to watch unboxings
of stuffs but like I don't know actually
it's just another trend on YouTube yeah
so yeah that's all you know it's like it
was great it wasn't for us I don't think
we ever tried to do it like maybe one or
two times sometimes if the packaging is
really cool like put on yeah on camera
like to show you really don't think
about a headphones right right like we
unbox those on camera like that there's
a cool box to show we'll show it like hi
everyone knows that an iPhone box is
like if that's that's what you really
enjoy like that's just what you do like
I'll go buy you one and you can watch it
yourself I'll give you my box okay
exactly while you do for me like you
know I don't know it's just one of those
trends in YouTube and I've been seeing a
lot more of those recently with like the
community building and you know as I
mentioned before how the text meters
interesting I'm glad are you interested
we're in a bubble and I kind of we were
in a tech bubble know like that's why
like when when Keaton first came over
and we were hanging out talking about it
it was interesting to hear how his world
might be different than my world or his
perception of YouTube is very different
than my perception of YouTube because we
have we come from different worlds
within the same space but you guys
really are in a bubble and sometimes
it's comforting to hear like maybe
what's stressing you out isn't a big
deal with someone else and vice versa
sure you know yeah I think it's like the
best thing about working in this space
is like yeah ever since
move from my old home which I was not a
fan of uh I have like friends that like
can help comfort me if like I'm getting
stressed about YouTube stuff and it's
not really YouTube but it's more about
the other social media but that's what
they dominate in like I'm not trying to
be cocky and say like I dominate YouTube
it like video is my platform so cocky
and I'm offended now and they have
nothing to do with Peck which is like
good I like the diverse exotic we don't
like of your hangout with tech YouTube
resolve
none zero zero zero two zero tech
youtubers ya know we do our own thing so
you don't house any I don't know that
you do hang out any other time no well
actually not I'm not doing every night
no I remember like when you get me up
here you tweet at me or whatever saying
like what's up i watch your like blog
yeah I that was the first connection or
a talk or conversation I have with
anyone in the tech space so yeah you're
yeah but like there's also like there's
not too much drama at all either you
know and yeah you see so much uh well
there's there's dry sea and then Israel
you don't but there's not like there's
not like a civilizing underage yeah it's
not against architect right gene would
love to be on keemstar if we woke up one
morning and he said his name on Team
Star game days bat god he secretly would
love to be on keemstar if we really like
I know we can when he sends something on
the record thumbnail of kid Yahtzee I
was I keep my name jumble [ __ ] mom
but it was just a congratulations good
um that's good that you got so you're
saying within the tech world of YouTube
though you guys don't have any like
there's no hate going on you guys
respect each other for the most known
for the most part I feel like that's
what they were saying there's obviously
strife in anything ever
yeah that goes on
yeah absolutely but I mean it's not like
people openly hate each other no there's
not like college it's more than civilize
like it is I feel like it's just like
more it's a more civilized community
yeah it's also point of Awesome we're
like you go at someone by like
publishing your video and it's like if
we won we beat you to that like that was
that was how we attack like it's weird
to say that's like it's like music but
it's a mutual it's a mutual respect like
if you only beat someone you're like
okay bebe yeah I run they could just
make the same video now okay so most
mostly meet yours but yeah most of you
chose such so but what else I like where
do you guys where do you guys see
yourselves going or where do you want if
you've seen yourself in fact no not even
like that I just asked the question she
hates being asked not you can't even
like that it's just like you you want it
to be Keaton based and you want people
to yeah um like entertainment yeah like
I never considered myself an entertainer
until I got out here but like if I look
at the roots of it that's what I am um I
don't know if that's a good or a bad
thing but like I still want the channel
to be entertaining and I also want to be
doing acting and stuff that is comedy
based cuz like I know I'm funny like
Matt knows that like I've been told I'm
funny so like a goddamn big comedian now
but like I want to pursue avenues on
that that aren't just product based so I
think that's what I want to be doing in
five years it's just stoned social space
and I mean just to answer for like Matt
and what I'd like it I'd like him to be
there with me because like he is been my
best friend has really great insight on
like anything I do and it's just like
it's a valuable opinion that like I've
not seen in any other individual I'm
like I don't know it's a really rare
perspective totally it's like a never in
said that like what you guys have is so
close I'm like easy like easy does it
there tiger but I don't you know I I
always say I would love to find a
YouTube channel there's like the same
kind of scope as I like but also like
I'm so closer related but I on the chin
you know I'm saying yeah like she gets
recognized I don't get recognized no one
for you my kinky on
that's actually a great example of never
bro science life never Donizetti
Donizetti oh okay what did it like what
it is uh like Perry fitness videos but
his off-screen writer partner is his
50/50 partner B and if they caught Mike
and Gyan right that's the thing like
anyway it's when I first met Kenan and
then I met you it was very very unique
to see the relationship you guys had and
how functional was especially for how
young you are
you don't see that which is something
like you appreciate especially what you
know I'm dating Jenna we work in the
same space but even a family friend yeah
yeah for me yeah together you work
together you know everything together do
you guys have like the same situation
name Julian's yeah yeah no that's it's
it's cool though I I respect that we can
yeah a lot of our fees that's a thing no
miss you don't know cuz we do it but
it's an iceberg and do you see that the
video is the tip yeah and what's below
the water is like that yeah it's certain
like it's so like I have to prove effort
it's a group effort for sure I respect
youtubers that can do it all on their
own
I'm not one of those youtubers yeah and
and you don't claim to be you know what
your sisters you know exactly yeah which
is awesome but um II I don't know really
happy at Matt here especially right now
we're doing a lot of big stuff and uh no
it's why did you move out yay I just
came in January 4 and we just like
crushed it we did I know we did a glitch
it what do we have how many subscribers
me like we had 600 at the start and we
just passed 950 yeah that's awful yeah a
third of that and like millions max like
yeah yeah yeah I'm excited like I didn't
you guys that it's famine like our baby
for a while it's a really big deal and
you guys should be really proud like
there's a lot of work and thank you
congratulations giving up a lot gave up
my entire high school career never fired
in high school it's good career never
partied in high school my friends guys
you miss you know if you're not checking
out techsmartt go to their YouTube
channel link below it's youtube.com
slash tech because Keaton has all the
URLs all the usernames ah
but thank you guys
oh yeah this is seriously a really
interesting conversation kid I thank you
for having one yeah of course physical
um thanks I'm so cool we'll see you see
you every Monday Tuesday Friday Sunday
for a little bit and very wanna we'll
see you on with that yeah my friend
they're telling it's like I'm editing
four videos a week
Oh any of you that is that that a is
that a plural I heard or Matt another
certainty like Oh guys you're an out is
real burnout is the thing I'm record
burnout I'm just like you guys attitude
about it yeah I guess if you have to
edit ten videos a day then Joe they need
some headspace it's fine just rush there
you go there you go let's check out
headspace go ahead space.com slash
annejulien uh again we appreciate you
guys coming on the podcast thank you for
having me anything else that you wanna
see are you are you working on anything
oh oh yes I need the true honest opinion
okay which because I don't keel say okay
these jeans I just got them I like ugly
a thing or does it go I think you are
with that hat though
oh yeah sure we kind of match that sure
I just yeah it's a good I like your STIs
dude you got no and I think though you
know it sure would I think that they'll
ever talk about all right because I was
getting some weird looks in the airport
but that's probably because you are
wearing a banana which I would have done
too we were in pajamas beardsley true
it's a cool hat it's a dad has another
$30 where'd you get that forever 21 I've
never shopped there and my dude they
just they just they just broke away the
men's section yeah in our local one it's
gone in 98% women's none there's like a
tiny little point that you man hugs
substantial guys sec and now it's gone
they were like [ __ ] is totally gone well
I think it's so narrow to like one
corner but it's not us going in on this
team all right
you see mom good mom oh the best one
never FYE did you ever go to FIU pretty
sure yet it was arcade and I have the
music yeah yeah this does whatever 21 is
now they've dumped that boy F we got
dumped a long time ago but FY you was
now
relish it nobody town in New York why as
well we'll wrap it up safer Rochester
come back we're going to the Rochester
which they can do all that I don't know
I didn't realize I grew up so we'll see
you guys next week for another podcast
hopefully you've enjoyed the guests we
have we actually will have another guest
next week to wherever coming back a nice
streak no they're not we're having a
better we're having a nice streak of
guests is this that's four weeks urges
no we know yes a Debbie okay uh nice low
streaky guess so we'll see you guys next
week forecast a pink see you guys later
pink